[Music]
a man paid
three thousand pounds
to have his penis lengthened and widened
wow
what's the usd on that yo [ __ ] i paid
you five thousand pounds for the same
exact [ __ ] thing so one person no no
one point five times man
whatever all right i'm in i can do that
wow it's 3 600 euros or i really don't
know the conversion right now i didn't
know you could do that what's the
success rate define success
it works what you want it's meaty
when you're making love yeah and your
love making it works man it works i'm
just worried about nerve then
yeah nerve damage is yeah because like
it's like what if you get this nice ass
dick but then you don't you lose the
feeling of it so you're just like oh
what
you're gonna feel more you're gonna feel
more i'd rather have a small ass dick
with hella nerves
than a big-ass dick with no nerves so
this is four thousand seventy three
dollars roughly not no nerf how much for
that amount of money do you think your
penis is going to grow or one thousand
dollars about four thousand dollars four
x
for every thousand that is very
optimistic
[Laughter]
first of all four hecks of penis yeah
that's too much that's not a subtle
change that's like eight inches you
gotta be a one centimeter eight inches i
wanna i'm carrying a baseball bat in my
pants if you got a microphone your dick
is one centimeter long that's four
inches
well that
this guy enlarged his penis by less than
an inch but i think i think what i think
that's the only way it works girth or
length it just has less than an inch is
there a picture no i wonder if that's
specifically what he wanted yeah that's
not working that's not worth it but is
it but the guy with the biggest penis in
the world apparently every time he gets
erect he passes out because so much
blood flows to his business
like you don't want the biggest but you
still like if you get a height thing
right yeah you want to be like five
eleven six feet you wanna be you wanna
be a big fish in a small pond yeah
you're gonna be six nine yeah but you
also don't wanna just go like from like
five three to five four yeah
yeah cause what's the point yeah you
might as well live your life at five
yeah like but then again you do have a
bragging right over all the people that
are fighting now ratios it's all ratios
if this guy goes less than an inch but
that was like a 25 increase that's still
a change that's true because what if he
was a like
you know maybe it was emotional maybe he
did it for himself
sometimes you do things for yourself man
half inch away from happiness here's a
question i wish i wish gio was here we
could ask a woman you can ask me
do you think do you think someone could
actually feel the difference between the
say it was three inches to four inches
do you think so let's find out he'll go
first and i'll go second let's go hey i
can feel the difference i i think in
this guy's case it wasn't so much a
physical thing it might have also been
an emotional emotional man of course of
course that's the reason why the guy
does it but i did i think i have asked
jill like the the biggest dude you've
been with and in high school she was
with the dude that
with two hands you could still see it
come out whoa i was like that's not fair
is that because you're like you're like
imagining it you're like you're like so
so it was like this
like this that's not fair man
that's the best person jill got big
hands
so what did she say about it oh what did
she say what does gio the expert say
about it i think i think it's about the
love yeah
[Laughter]
i just mean she's super about your
personality part yeah
so this guy's name is murat
that made me sad i'm sorry dude
i'll feel
36 year old he went to visit a doctor in
hanover who specializes in the
autologous fat method
uh which uh that gives two centimeters
in length and girth they just pull out
your
girds they actually pull it out from
your stomach
yeah because it has some excess yeah
some slack like a brazilian dick lift
i'll do that
we could all just practice wushu and
just like drag our dick with the trucks
like you've seen those guys like the
guys who were like the qigong the chi
gong masters they're like now watch my
my scrotum pull a [ __ ] 18 wheeler and
that thing has pulled out that you know
just the scrotum gets super light
makes it look shorter yeah the rotor the
dick ratio is a little high i like the
kung fu masters that have like logs
[ __ ] what do you call those door
barricade busters just batteries the
batteries the battering ram to their
dicks
so you got it pulled out a little bit
out of his stomach
so there's different methods but this is
the method he use uh this specialist uh
is a specialist in plastic and aesthetic
surgery from um a clinic that performs
the operation constantly he this dude
who's 36 year old years old was unhappy
with the length of his manhood which
measured only 7.5 centimeters which is
three inches
whereas the german average length is
around 13 centimeters which is five
inches
when erect oh so he just wanted to be
average yeah so he's he said he's been
trying for years his dick now is not
no he's the second biggest dick in the
world
he went from average to like top of the
mountain he only passes out a little bit
yeah he gets a little like he's like i
can't pass out every single time i get
aroused he said he said he's been trying
for years to increase the length of his
member
he tried pills creams penis pumps
expanders and all that he spent over a
thousand euros but nothing helped the
penis that's the dude clicking on all
the [ __ ] tabs that pop up and then
and then he mentioned he's the [ __ ]
reason
and then he mentioned that you know
partners and stuff like that told him
right to his face one time that he just
wasn't well equipped
wow
yeah so so this doctor uh who performs
over 300 operations a year i'm sorry all
of us literally we all looked at each
other like super sad that was the most
emotional moment on the show ever
visually huddled we all gave each other
yeah we i made eye contact every person
everyone was like oh cause that sucks to
say jesus yeah that's gotta that's gotta
be the way it's gone oh i'm thinking
about it it's making me emotional you
could you could say that to a dude with
a gigantic dick and he'll still feel sad
for sure 100 it doesn't matter
so there are two methods to change the
size of a penis which is surgical
lengthening with ligaments and the
second is the enlargement of the member
with autologous fat italian where did
they get the ligament your knee
so he just has a [ __ ] up acl
[Laughter]
they take your elbows
so your dick could just be like a tetris
piece
and the operation takes about 60 minutes
by the way so it only takes 60 minutes
yeah but are you an emphasis
because that'll be crazy if you're just
sitting there and the [ __ ] doctor's
just working on your dick and you're
just like guys why did i want to
interview with diane sawyer and you're
good to go let's watch the prince
andrews [ __ ] all this interrogation
we've been watching one hour shows not
getting our dick lengthened
have you guys
spot recently no i don't know what but
i've been i've been we love that place i
went last month in the pandemic dude
you're risking it i was like is it
[ __ ] big dick dancing
everyone was [ __ ] like just hanging
around like this and i was like
what the [ __ ] is going on
today ask somebody
i have a question because i've only been
to wii spa
in the middle
in the middle of the night because what
i do is i i go to oh it's gay spa though
no bro so i go to congo dong that korean
bbq place
yeah yeah
we're like i'm [ __ ] full and i've got
the meat sweats what should we do let's
go get some real dongs but then when you
go at like two in the morning
on like a thursday
there's some weird people in no it's a
it's a gay spot dude well one time i
went in there they hook up see that i've
never seen a dab but i saw one dude flat
out i saw one dude flat out naked
sitting on a bucket
right a bucket yeah like taking the [ __ ]
like it's turned upside down squatting
on the ground shaving okay but like
we're all in there like running around
naked like i'm like doing pirouettes and
like jumping from the hot tub to the
cold tub
i'm just like yeah exactly i'm like i'm
like tiptoeing i'm like oh it's cold
you know what i mean because i'm butt
ass naked they give you razors and stuff
so yeah but like this dude is sitting
there right like shaving and he's like
like he's like looking at people
the hot tub area not in the shower area
you know how it is like they have the
hot tub and it's like the all the
mirrors are on the like you see people
sitting on the floor where they can
shower
have you been in there for like in a
year or two yeah there's like there's
that shower roll yeah it used to be like
a family environment and when it became
mainstream it became like a hookup spot
wow yeah so then because um
one of our fans is a security guard
there and he was telling me like once it
became like everybody went there
everyone in like hollywood la whatever
uh
then you know guys would kind of like
hit on each other and then they would
start making out or like [ __ ] jacking
each other off or whatever yeah and he'd
be like i had to call the cops on him
and sometimes he he's like i'm going in
there hitting the bathroom door like
stop guys and they're [ __ ] so hard
he's like they got hornier when he was
telling them to stop and he's like [ __ ]
do you think they go into like the the
jade room and just like hook up with
each other you know what i'm talking
about they've got the clay room and the
jade room in the ice room let's go get
the cedar exactly
like meet me where the moth ball
like that doesn't make it hotter bro i
think dude if someone told like they
want to hook up in the jade room because
that's you know that's pretty tight
that's pretty baller they say we spa but
we were in a spa like that in korea and
then um you know how they do the body
scrub thing right and then um our buddy
came out and he's like hey um
did your guys the guy like sit on you
shut up and we're like
what
he goes wait
what was he wearing and then
um he was a nude right and i'm all like
wait your guy got naked he goes no no he
had no he had the speedos on and i'm
like yeah speedos
because they usually wear like a polo
shirt and whatever and they're scrubbing
yeah and he goes no like so when i was
laying down
he said the dude
[ __ ] got on his chest and scrubbed
like this is speedo on top of him i've
seen dudes do that because i guess like
you know what how they uh spray your
dead skin off after yeah i've seen the
dude do that and then he just did
himself too
so i guess if he's in his speech
that was in the skin he was spraying
he was on him going like this
i went to india i got a massage at this
spot and they don't traditionally give
you a like female to a male or male 2
feel it's the same gender
and so
the dude was like straight up in his
underwear and i swear to god at one
point this is like totally normal he
he obviously puts like sesame oil or
whatever coconut oil to massage me he
then covers his body
and no joke i swear to god i'm like when
i'm there i'm like yo weird whatever who
cares did he start sliding on you yeah
he flat out [ __ ] just like runs like
slip and slide and just like slides
across my [ __ ] back and i'm like face
down like this and i'm like i'm pretty
sure that dude just slipped and slided
like right over my ass that's isn't that
called massage that was a good technique
i'm gonna do it like did you get credit
card with his dick i was like oh [ __ ]
this is new
all right it's pretty good i'm gonna do
it
i'm still alive it's all good maybe you
make your [ __ ] up dude you're just like
you're just like don't get a boat yeah
i'm like you know what i'm like this
massage this massage cost me 15
all in like when it's like a super
high-end spot
[Music]